all right we're gonna go in and outline
it how do you navigate an airplane it's
become a lot easier now in the GPS age
but you still have to know a little bit
about how people used to do it in the
old days partly to pass the exam and
partly because it's interesting all
right so we're gonna talk about looking
out the window that's called pilotage
planning your flight and then looking
out the window we'll talk about the old
non-directional beacons basically homing
in on a radio station 1950s there were
something called the vor that we'll talk
about it lets you figure out exactly
your magnetic heading to or from a radio
station and finally the way that most
people get around these days is the GPS
and the moving map okay so when you're
doing pilotage you come up an advanced
with a bunch of visual landmarks that
you think you'll be able to see from the
air you're gonna cross the river you're
gonna find a reservoir you're gonna see
a big radio tower you're gonna pass a
town that has the name of the town
written in a high school athletic field
and the VFR charts they emphasize I
think you saw that maybe with the iPad
or we have charts up here we can look at
it later but they emphasize objects that
you can as a practical matter see from
the air so the procedure we'll go
through this carefully is you plot your
plan course using a pencil and a ruler
essentially on the chart you select what
checkpoints are going to be visible on
your flight you measure the distance
from point to point and then you've got
this plan of what heading you're gonna
steer you get the forecast winds as well
so you say look I'm gonna fly this it's
gonna I'm gonna be going 100 knots over
the ground I'm gonna be being blown off
course very slightly by a crosswind from
the north you plan all that and then
you've got your nav log so as you reach
each checkpoint you can make a
correction and well it took me a little
bit longer to get here I'm a little bit
left of where I thought I was so you can
make these Corrections as you go along
all right so here's an example let's say
you wanted to go from MIT to Bennington
College to visit a friend well there's
an airport right there called DDH and
it's about 90 nautical miles I think I
did this with the sky vector so your
planning goal is to come up with this
navigation log so you're gonna say okay
I'm gonna depart Hanscom field up there
at the top and it's gonna take me looks
like it's gonna take me nine nine
nautical miles before I reach my
cruising altitude and about four minutes
then after that it's gonna take me five
minutes to reach Fitchburg Airport which
is an airport two great landmarks
they're very easy to see and they have
distinctive shapes and notice here the
magnetic course is 298 but with the wind
we're gonna have to correct that and
steer to 92 and of course the compass
card with the deviations indicated might
give us another degree or two but
basically from the wind that wind
correction is going to have a steering a
slightly different course anyway so
you're going to come up with this nav
log of how long it's going to take what
course you're gonna steer from your
compass and as you go along you're
basically doing what's called dead
reckoning
it's tough over the ocean because
there's not any landmarks oh you know
those early pilots who went over oceans
were real heroes if you're going over
the land you can actually make these
Corrections so the procedure is just as
I said you plot the course on the chart
you measure the true course so let's say
you're going straight north that's going
to be zero then you correct two for the
forecast wind to find the true heading
and you correct for the magnetic
variation because remember you're in
aircraft sources are magnetic heading
not true heading and finally you're
going to estimate the ground speed and
estimated time and route
leg alright let's talk about some terms
when you think of them let's reinforce
them your course with the direction over
the ground but your heading is going to
be in general different from the course
due to wind true is you know if you
steer true north you'll get to the North
Pole and hang out with Santa Claus if
you go magnetic you'll go to a slightly
different place every time all right
magnetic variation we had this chart
pretty much before so unless you're
somewhere down in Florida or looks like
in Chicago there's going to be some
correction from true to magnetic the
local magnetic variation remember is
indicated on the chart so it's right
here 14 degrees west and remember again
if you get confused about how to how
true and magnetic relate just look at a
vor diagram here's an example a compass
card that you might see in your aircraft
I haven't seen any you know that are
quite this dramatic I think this is for
effect but you can see it says look if
you want to fly you know 60 degrees a
heading of zero six zero oh if you want
to go east instead of steering zero nine
zero steer 85 on your compass it gets
updated every couple years I think and
as an editor earlier if you have things
in the airplane or systems like a heated
wind chill turned on the compass may
become kind of worthless all right so
let's get out the tools we're gonna go
through these more with flight planning
but basically you get your sectional
chart Tina showed you this
I have one too I just got it yesterday
at East Coast Aero Club front desk
flight schools usually sell them I think
there are missing out on the revenue now
that it's all free on skyvector and
similar sites you've got your plotter so
this is basically a ruler and the ruler
is on top and statute miles I'm not sure
when you would ever want to use that but
on the bottom you have nautical miles
which is what we generally use in the
aviation world and you have this
protractor that you might remember from
elementary school that helps you figure
out on the chart what the true course is
going to be all right so I think you
guys can probably figure out how to use
that this is the e6b flight computer so
I think the e6b designation comes from
the US military I'm not exactly sure
when this came out probably it says in
Wikipedia but I'm assuming it was a
World War 2 era kind of device and it
lets you make all kinds of computations
of density altitude of how fast you're
going you know truly through the air
depending on what as a function of your
altitude and what you're seeing on your
airspeed indicator it lets you on the
backside correct for wind you can make
pencil marks and then start twisting to
figure out whether the wind is going to
give you a reduction or a boost in
airspeed and also how much of a course
correction you're going to need so it's
a very useful instrument now fortunately
it comes with instructions because your
modern pilots have mostly forgotten how
to use this it's kind of a historical
artifact at this point but we'll go
through some of it so you'll get a
flavor for it and it is fun all right so
you put your plotter down on the chart
and as you can see you'll be able to
read from the protractor depending on
the line that you've drawn
what the course is I will tell you that
one of the most important skills of your
old school flight instructor is drawing
a straight line from one side of the
chart to the other I can't tell you how
to do it it's a really complicated
folding system that enables you to
actually draw a coarse line when you
have to flip the chart over to get from
your source and destination airports
okay using the plotter you can see
people's charts they would have to buy
new ones you know every few weeks
because they would be so marked up with
pencils here we find the true course is
zero three eight so as you can see
they're just reading that off the
protractor part there are paper East six
B's and metal ones so this is a picture
of a paper one again you can kind of see
that you can just set up for example
that we're gonna go 90 knots and then
that's here if we go 90 knots then it
will take us ten minutes to go
fifteen miles not very exciting the wind
side is more interesting you can get
your ground correct you can get your
ground speed and your wind correction
angle that's the most important thing so
this one is hard enough to use that they
actually put the instructions right on
the top here on the back of the e6b so
they say you know place the wind
direction under the true index we'll go
through this anyway the winds from two
one zero and we're trying to fly
straight south a true course of one
eight zero at an airspeed of 147 knots
through the air we've already computed
that and the winds twenty knots from two
one zero so we're trying to go south
let's say this is let's say this is
South at one eight zero and the wind is
coming from the right so when we're all
done I sure hope
that the answer will be that we have to
steer a little bit to the right of one
eight zero true at least alright so here
we are on the wind side we start by
marking 147 knots it looks like and then
we rotate it you can see that pencil
mark has been rotated off it started at
210 let's let's go back yeah so we had
the we had it set up to 210 says wind
direction under true index then we
marked the velocity then we twisted it a
little bit so now we've got an index of
South and we can read that our ground
speed will have fallen right there under
the little grommet there to 129 knots
and the wind correction angle is going
to be 4 degrees you can read that off of
this little scale here see it says 5 and
10 anyway so we do all that which is
very tedious it's based on a forecast
again of the winds aloft so it's never
going to be exactly right and we use it
to fill out one of these navigation log
forms once it's all filled out you can
see that it's a lot easier to do if you
just ask some computer application to do
it for you like sky vector is free and
it will will do it for you using the
forecast winds then when you're flying
along as I said you make corrections so
here for example unfortunately the one
bad thing about sky vector I put in
these user fixes beam the Fitchburg
Airport and crossing the Connecticut
River I think because I thought those
would be easy to see from the air but
unfortunately there's no way to name
them in sky vector so they're just come
out as user fix but you know maybe you
could write that in with the pencil
anyway so you can see here
the wind is forecast to be you know from
272 at 15 knots you're going 140 knots
of true airspeed your track over the
ground is supposed to be 287 true minus
2 degrees wind correction angle I just
did this actually for Sunday night I
think the true heading therefore will be
285 but then you'll have to add 16
degrees for the local variation so
you'll end up with a magnetic heading of
301 so you steer that for a while
see how it goes it's supposed to take
you about 12 minutes from the time you
took off to the time you reach that
point and you write down what actually
happened and if you see the airport
while let's see it's supposed to be on
our left if you see the airport on your
right you say well the winds not quite
what I thought I'm gonna steer 10
degrees right and then that river
crossing I guess isn't really ideal for
heading correction you probably want to
find some other landmarks as well
all right why we did so question
they do I think Tina might know I think
the wins are all off your forecast
either 24 or 30 hours in advance yeah
that's a good question we can look that
up we can look that up for you later but
yeah so you can do it about you can also
you can kind of predict to some extent
with prevailing winds some of some of
these applications will work with
averages and so forth if it's not there
but yeah within 24 hours you have a
pretty good wind forecast but again with
the modern GPS system you know you can
kind of immediately see what you're
going of course and the autopilot may
automatically make the correction for
you anyway so this is kind of a
historical lecture it's good to know
what I would say is well yeah so what I
would say is it's still worth doing but
I would say generate the nav log
electronically it's not really worth
doing anymore like the full pain the
knowledge test does have a built-in
electronic e6b the tests are not that
demanding except that you will need the
plotter so they'll give you a supplement
with a bit of a chart and you kind of
need the plotter to figure out how far
it is from place to place on the real
test that's if you want to get a hundred
the yeah you see the summary of how it
works it's a fun skill I will tell you I
saw I had two interactions on basically
the same day I met an alum an alumna of
this course at East Coast Aero Club and
she was hearing tearing up a storm with
an e6b and fulfilling out the nav log
and doing all this I said what why are
you doing that every every East Coast
area called plane has a garmin 430 in it
you know just punch in your destination
and you can go and she said and if that
doesn't work you know call up air
traffic control and tell him you're lost
so she said well like every flight with
my instructor he you know he fails
everything he makes me you know go back
and assume that everything's broken and
do it all old-school and manually so she
was doing this on every cross-country
flight that she was doing both dual and
solo
and I said well you know that's good I'm
not sure how much relationship has to
safety because the other interaction I
had that day was with a commercial pilot
instrument-rated who we wanted to rent
the Cirrus and I was the previous user
of the airplane so I said how much fuel
do you want he said I wanted topped off
I said you're gonna fly for six hours we
go where where you go I said I'm going
to Albany I said what it's an hour away
what do you want six hours of fuel for
he said the airport I'm going to doesn't
have any fuel I said Albany's a
crosswind runway runway there is longer
than hanscom's main runway it's 7,500
feet you know I got a beautiful FBO it's
basically free what do you mean they
have no fuel and he wanted to go to this
other Airport it was on the east side of
town it was actually farther from his
destination he was taking his son to
Rensselaer and the big airports actually
closer and this was a twenty five
hundred foot airport with a note in the
chart supplement saying to call a phone
number before you even try to go there
to check out the local conditions it's
unattended if you blow a tire there's no
way to get a mechanic out there other
than maybe driving from Albany or Boston
so it has a displace threshold to is
2500 feet but because of the trees on
both ends you're not supposed to land
right on the numbers you actually land a
few like 500 feet or 400 feet down the
runway so I said you know the Cirrus
takes about 2,100 feet to land over a
50-foot obstacle so you're budgeting to
use more than 60% of the runway which
you know the airline minimum is you have
to plan to land in 60% that way if you
are a little bit sloppy you don't go off
the end of the runway and hit something
so I said you know like why would you
give yourself with your son less safety
margin and a to pilot and airline crew
and so he said well you know like I
don't want to deal with an FBO which was
really weird to me so basically there's
no point to that story other than
now there is a point to that story
there's no point to that story you know
safety is not about like doing
everything really tedious it's it's more
about you know having reasonable
judgment and asking like why am I better
than a two-pilot arrow airline crew so
yeah it's not she was smart she's an
engineer so of course it doesn't over
tax her to do this kind of stuff but
let's not really confuse it with adding
safety which is more about having the
judgment to know when to take a copilot
or when to make your life easier by
going to an airport with a really long
runway alright let's talk about ATF's
this was very exciting in 1952
have a look there that was Lear some of
you have probably heard of Learjet so
the founder of Learjet was also the
inventor of the first kind of practical
car radios so all the money that was
made on car radios was eventually turned
into an aviation company and before the
Learjet there were these avionics that
made it super easy to figure out where
the station was so they have I think at
the very first the pilot would tune or
the Navigator more likely would twist
this dial and here when of this tone
reached some kind of maximum and then
there was the automatic direction finder
which would just point the needle in
that direction of the station see here
it's just pointing if yeah here's
something you know this is from the
pilots handbook I think on how to use an
NDB but you can see that with a with a
heavy wind you don't end up really
tracking exactly towards the station
alright so relative bearing is you know
how far do your left your right the
station is and then you can get the
magnetic bearing if you add your own
heading in there so it's not rocket
science if you're going south and the
station is 90 degrees to your left then
the magnetic bearing to the station is
going to be I guess
well I guess the bearing to the station
would be zero nine zero in that case all
right this was an exciting thing where
you could actually turn the card on your
ADF so if you were heading Northwest of
heading a330 you would twist that and
then you just without having to think
you can see it would be you have to fly
roughly with no wind you would fly to
one zero and to get to the station
you'll find that it's only a plane I
guess some planes that operate in Europe
a lot they were requiring this to later
planes that just have a lot of stuff in
the panel still may have this but in
general they're hard to find now the ORS
are still around
they have 360 radials that the radio
receiver can just identify so the
receiver can just say I know that I'm
exactly south or I know that I'm exactly
east or I know that I'm exactly zero six
zero direction from this station so
you'll be able to know where you are and
if you can tune in to different ones and
you've got your handy pencil out and
your chart in the aircraft you can draw
intersecting lines and figure out where
you are on the chart so again in the
moving map GPS days this is not as
exciting a skill as it once was I think
there are a few questions about you know
symbols on the chart for different kinds
of vor s so one thing is distance
measuring equipment where by sending out
a pulse and having the station send that
back to the aircraft it's possible by
measuring the transit time to actually
get your distance in nautical miles you
know read out to you and the cockpit
be advised that's the actual you know
distance through the air so it's not the
horizontal distance projected over the
ground but if you're up a few miles it
might be and you're close to the vor I
might be slightly different
service volumes there are these terminal
VOR s I think a lot of maybe
decommissioned or being decommissioned
now but the FAA has made various kinds
of vor s these high-altitude ones will
probably be the last to go because
actually with airliners the
certification costs of new avionics are
so high that you know the last aircraft
flying without a GPS will be some huge
Boeing it won't be a little you know a
piper or Stearman or something okay the
parts of the vor
so you have this thing called the Omni
bearing selector which you can tune here
and on the canonical instrument here all
it does is rotate this card around the
top so that is to pick out the radio
that you want and then you get the two
from flag so you can see here this is
showing you that the three six serial
three six zero radial is off to your
left and if we were to fly we don't have
to this is not related to the actual
heading of the aircraft but if we were
to fly basically north we'd be going
away from the vor
okay we'll get we're going to get into
this more the HSI down there offers you
the same information but superimposed on
the aircraft's actual heading which
makes life a lot easier okay how do you
test your vor know that it's actually
going to work there are these vor test
stations or vo T's test facilities if
you can remember Cessna 182
every VOT puts out the same signal and
what you should see is an indication of
- when you dial up and it should be
centered on the 180 radio so that's how
you know if your view are always working
if you're gonna use it for instrument
flight you have to test them every 30
days alright let's have a look you're
gonna probably have to study and think
about this a little bit more at home but
one easy way to think about this is to
sort of build yourself a virtual HSI so
if you see a test question
and it shows the indicator set up to
tune to like the zero three zero radio
just like draw a little airplane or
imagine an airplane actually heading
northeast on a zero three zero heading
so you can see this airplane in the at
left this one it's showing that the zero
three zero radio is to the right of the
wing assuming we were actually heading
zero three zero and that we're going
vaguely to towards the vor because the
two flag is set up over here it's the
same but it's the front flag over here
on the right we've got the radial off to
our left and we're going from the vor
over here again the radials to our left
and we're going to so just like let that
sink in a little bit I think I'm gonna
show you an FAA written test question so
you just know says the vor is turned to
the Elizabeth City vor that I believe is
right over if you want to know the value
of a marketing degree this Elizabeth
City is right next to a big place called
the dismal swamp the dismal swamp park
anyway so if you've there anywhere near
the dismal swamp and you want to go
visit and you're at Elizabeth City tuned
to the vor it says the aircraft just
positioned over Shaw borrow one of the
hardest things about this is finding
Shaw bar on the map that I've drawn it
there for you
so we're northeast of the vor and it
says which vor indication is correct to
which is at the top there eight or nine
on the bottom what do you guys think so
we're we're northeast of Shaw borough
who wants to vote for two two-one-zero
from nobody who wants to vote for eight
that's zero three zero two who wants to
vote for nine a few hands yay okay so
basically we're right on the radio so
show up or oh you can see here at the
end of the arrow it is I think that
actually might say I don't know what
that says actually have no idea
ten twenty thirty yeah it's right there
at the 30 okay
so it's definitely on the zero three
zero radio which is also the two one
zero radio the reciprocal I mean this is
not a total trivial question but if we
were to fly to one zero we would be
going to the flag should be two if we
were actually flying Southwest we'd be
heading towards the vor so it should be
a two flag if we're flying away from the
vor further out on zero three zero and
it should be a from flag which is not an
eight and this one is the only one
that's consistent as if we actually were
to fly zero three zero we'd be going
away from the vor don't sweat it if you
haven't got it there is actually a cool
simulator and Adobe Flash which was
actually cool when you guys were born
and a oppa also I've linked here to the
airline the airplane owners and Pilots
Association the big lobbying group for
private aviation they have a list of I
don't think they're free unfortunately
that sim that web simulator is free but
there's little simulators you can get on
your phone for vor s that used to be
really important I mean GPS is now more
important basically it was a 1973 US
military ID idea if you just broadcast
the time and the position of a bunch of
satellites from the satellites then the
receiver can see how long did it take to
get from the satellite to where the
receiver is so if you think about it
let's say
one of the transmitters is by that exit
sign so if I know my distance from the
exit sign that puts me on a sphere of
uncertainty right I could be up in the
ceiling I could be down on the first
floor I could be in a lot of different
places as long as I know that I'm let's
call it 30 feet from the exit sign okay
well that's not great because I'm still
pretty uncertain about where I am but
how about you know if there's another
transmitter in that corner of the room
that gives me a second sphere two
spheres will intersect intersect in a
circle I believe so now we have a circle
of uncertainty and we pick up another
transmitter maybe somewhere over there
so the more satellites we can see the
more intersecting spheres we have and
eventually we'll get down to a very
small little area of uncertainty indeed
so that's how GPS works you just rely on
the fact that the speed of light is
constant if you know the distance to
each of a bunch of satellites and you
know where they are then at that point
you know where you are
the thirty-two satellites as of 2016
we're up 31 we're in use you can always
see five for IFR the idea is to try to
get some redundancy there are some
tweaks to that system I think what I
just described would work really well in
outer space there's no atmosphere to
bend or distort any of the radio signals
but there is a certain amount of
distortion that happens and there are
these ground-based reference stations so
you know exactly where they are they
don't move and they listen to the
signals and they try to figure out how
much error there is as a result of the
signals traveling through the atmosphere
at that location those Corrections are
then pushed back up into space and sent
back down from the satellites to
ordinary receivers and with those
Corrections you can become really
accurate you can get accurate enough to
actually fly down right towards a runway
so the GPS signal
the GPS system which launched in the
mid-90s you know that enabled the moving
map and you never were lost again you
always knew where you were
but the Waze system is what enables
these GPS approaches where you navigate
in 3d you know to within I don't know
ten feet or something of precision right
down to the runway all right what does
it look like in practice this is the
pilots view this is a modern Garmin 750
it's a single box that actually has
three sub boxes and the sub boxes are
the GPS anavra do which lets you tune up
via wores and instrument landing system
for approaching the runway Tina may talk
about that a little bit tomorrow and a
little IFR intro and also a comm radio
and they actually I think they actually
have three separate power supplies so
there's a connection to the Box maybe
for power but after that you can you can
have tremendous amount of failure and
inside the box and still have the
functions the sub you know a subset of
the functions working I guess if the
screen fails you're kind of out of luck
which is by most IFR sort of every IFR
certified airplane that I know of it's
newish has a second one of these usually
smaller a Garmin 650 which is physically
smaller on the Garmin g1000 you know
it's even bigger it's on this huge
multifunction display if that fails you
can swap all the information over to the
primary flight display or vice versa so
that just gives you a little view to it
here and here here's your comm radio on
the g1000 and here's your nav radio and
see it's even identified the vor spot
Morse code signal and the garment has
listened to it and identified it as the
PPG vor the fjr vor all right the g1000
they also actually this is one of the
worst human factors design I think I've
ever seen wonder who else can identify
this like what what is tara what is
truly terrible about this design i'll
give you a hint it kind of well there's
the all the engine instruments on the
left there too
so what what kind of pretty common
failure accident causing failure does
this really not help you prevent
electrical that's not very common like
most most airplay I'll tell you that
most airplanes that you know have an
accident are in perfect mechanical
electrical and sheetmetal condition fuel
starvation so look yeah like your
battery your amps I mean basically fuel
is given the same status as all of this
stuff fuel is almost always relevant and
this other stuff is almost never
relevant and here it is it's small as
you run out of fuel as you get really
down into the red zone does this thing
grow you think it would grow to consume
half of the display it doesn't do
anything like that so I think it's a
terrible terrible design and aviation
really needs need some help a benign is
a little better I think on the user
interface this is a kind of a legacy
system from the Cirrus this shows you
this is NEXRAD data link weather we're
going to talk about that in a little bit
here's just a little thing about
navigation if you're going anywhere near
the DC area either get your instrument
rating and file IFR and then it becomes
like everywhere else or you have to take
this online course at some point and
learn about the special rules in the DC
area they're not that hard to go down to
Gaithersburg you have to VFR you have to
go in from certain gates you have to
file a flight plan in advance and you
have to keep a unique transponder code
so that air traffic control can track
you so if you have any brilliant ideas
for how folks in DC could do things
better you can just get in a little
Piper or Cessna or Cirrus that Hanscom
zip down to Gaithersburg and there you
are all right after the navigation
mistake so let's say you bust into class
Bravo airspace without a clearance or do
something else
that's you shouldn't have done the FAA
and NASA are really not there to bust
you there's a special form you can fill
out where you write down what you did
why you did it how you think things
could be improved you know maybe it was
a user interface issue maybe somebody
else was using the airplane before you
and turned off all the airspace alerts
you just fill up this form and mail it
in and that kind of limits the amount of
discipline that they can subject you to
I mean it doesn't protect you from
intentional violations all right here's
a summary pilotage ndb's vor and GPS
that was the progression over that
you've seen now a hundred years of
aviation navigation and I hope that
actually one thing that I hope this does
this give you a new appreciation for
some of the achievements people who flew
around the world in the 60s or the 50s
there's a woman jerry mauck I think is
her name it's a great book she flew a
Cessna tail dragger around the world in
the 1960s and you know she was often
lost she'd be over the ocean with icing
on her wings he would be having to track
you know ndb's in egypt or whatever so a
lot of that stuff has gotten so much
easier it's almost not fair you know and
you've got these data links so we can't
compare our achievements to the
achievements of pilots or the risk they
were taking to what the risk that folks
were taking in the old days you know
they didn't have EPIRBs if they went
into the water they didn't have you know
a moving map so they just didn't know
where they were most of the time you
know they had a vague idea all right so
this is for Francis this is a quote from
captain Sully's book the single pilot
airbus hero according to most to you so
he's got a failed GPS and a failed
compass Francis he says he could just
keep Venus in the left front corner of
the windshield and we would reach
California
what else could captain Saleh have done
as an alternative to using Venus
the Sun well it's nighttime
what Polaris yes actually the helicopter
follow an interstate highway that's a
helicopter common helicopter technique
probably because the interstates always
go through the to the lowest points how
about this one request vectors SFO you
could probably climb right out of the
hands come and call up Boston approach
and they would be happy to help at any
time actually and that is a good
question that's actually a good point
into crew resource management you know
don't try to be a single pilot hero
ideally if it's a challenging flight
you've got a co-pilot and even if you
don't have a co-pilot you always have
air traffic control as another crew
member all right let's take a few
questions who's got questions about
navigation so the question is can the
airplane show you your true altitude
based on the GPS signal and it's buried
in there it's not it can't be shown you
know on your altimeter in your primary
flight display but you can dig it out of
a you know either a separated GPS like
the Garmin for 750 or 430 or you know
the integrated glass panels like the
g1000 yes what you're navigating from
how you're being separated from other
aircraft that's all based on the static
information but if you just want to see
I know that mountains 8,000 feet high I
want to make sure it says at least 8,000
and why for actual altitude you can dig
that out and I think the terrain warning
system will use that
yes I'll repeat the question back for
the tape and anybody didn't hear so
basically in an older okay so you know
this phone has more computing power and
better design than everything inside a
Boeing 747 or an Airbus a380 in fact I
talked to the mayor bus a320 captain so
they said they wanted to get rid of
everything in the airplane except the
attitude indicator and they just wanted
to navigate off of an iPad running an at
a European app called sky demon which is
kind of like the American four foot your
Garmin pas they said you know that would
be just way better to just use the iPad
for everything so as a practical matter
in your you know ancient airplane that
might not even have an electrical system
yes of course you can navigate quite
effectively with some battery-powered
electronics or portable electronics that
you stick around the aircraft and the
interface can be very good and they have
you know comprehensive databases of
everything you'd want to know for legal
purposes and for practical ones for
instrument flying you have to have FA
certified stuff that's hardwired to the
aircraft and that's in the panel and you
know that makes sense because think
about it you know your phone may die the
battery may die so it's nice to have if
you want to do an instrument approach
for example you're going to need to have
something like even in an experimental
airplane you got to have one of those
certified like a Garmin 750 in there
you